President Biden failed to get his
request for more money for Ukraine
passed by Congress before it adjourned
until next year the White House had
thought it was being strategic in
bundling funding for an increasingly
unpopular war in Ukraine with money for
Israel Taiwan and border security but it
was the Republicans who sensed a
strategic opening realizing how
important funding for keev is to the
president Congressional Republicans have
held firm with remarkable Unity there
will be no additional funding for
Ukraine without tough new immig ation
policy from those who say enough
unconditional money has been spent on a
failed military operation in Ukraine the
Biden Administration seems to be asking
for is billions of additional dollars
with no appropriate oversight no clear
strategy to win to Hawks who argue the
goal isn't necessarily a victory for
Ukraine but to stand up for what they
call democracy and bleed Russia dry in
the process we're not losing track of
that it's just that border security
applies to us as well it didn't even
seem to matter that Aid to Israel was
also being jeopardized although the
Biden Administration has already
demonstrated it will bypass Congress to
get Israel whatever it says it needs
anyway the Republican strategy works the
White House now says that in return for
the money for Ukraine it is open to
increasing immigrant deportations and
reducing their ability to claim Asylum
this has infuriated some in the
Democratic party what is on the table
are policies so extreme that if enacted
it would literally be the most
exclusionary restrictive immigration
legislation since the racial quota laws
of the 1920s but the White House goes
into the election year betting that
however rightward the administration
pivots in the end the Bay will rally
around Joe Biden due to their fear of
Donald Trump the Bas is going to have to
decide ultimately in 2024 they're going
to have a choice between Donald Trump
and Joe Biden and the question is um
whom are they going to be able to
support and
um there are going to be some things
that President Biden did that they
really like a lot and there going to be
some things that they like less in the
end there wasn't enough time for a deal
on Border restrictions so Joe Biden ends
the year having enraged the Democratic
party base even further with his
capitulation to the right-wing on
immigration and having failed to secure
any more funding for a war in Ukraine
with which he is so closely aligned
himself shabans Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
Channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer click on the not